[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear me
[Music]
[Music]
you heard me
[Applause]
you should be able to hear me yeah I can
hear you
can you hear me King yes I can
it's
not letting me hear you again this week
be so many issues
okay you guys hear both of us
hello he said we here y'all
just out of curiosity
radic doesn't never let me let me know
that we're alive they should be able to
hear both of us
yeah they do that's what the chat said
all right can you hear me King
oh I I had to like change you up uh on
again I don't know what would be going
on with that
all right so mad as hell right now boy
they can hear you I know okay I'm just
making sure
I'm happy though I got a chance to meet
um
Brian
um and you know we uh made the trade so
uh Wolverine is gone and my PlayStation
Pro is in the house and my experiment is
shall begin
ah
no he can hear me now he had to adjust
the stuff
there we go
just making sure I'm not blurry am I
blurry to you
to me
you look fine to me a little blurry you
look a little blurry though
there we go that should be good now
there you go what's going on guys uh we
we're here man we're here we got some
stuff to talk about this week you know
we got some uh some Last of Us stuff to
talk about man uh did you watch the last
of a show
yes of course yeah I watched it too I
actually watched it with the weapon
wheel people but
I have seen it
and we're here to talk about it uh
first off let's get to the homework uh
did you get a chance to watch any Attack
on Titan or no yeah I did not get a
chance to watch any Attack on Titan
because uh technically this is supposed
to be my day to watch Attack on Titans
go into a fresh
um but being uh what's happening and
transpiring tomorrow
and I do apologize for anybody that was
uh listening to me eat uh addict didn't
tell me that we were live yes yes of
course guys yes of course you know so
um anyway so yeah I watched the last of
us today
and boy do I have a lot to say to
I'm curious when I curious what you uh
what you have to say so well I guess
we'll go ahead and get straight into you
know last of us let's talk about you
know over your all opinion on the matter
without you know we're not going to get
into spoilers right now yeah but I am
curious to hear your opinion on the
the you know in general uh so what what
was your opinion on it you know I mean
no spoilers I'm a huge nailed uh
druckman fan huge huge uh for the
ability to think outside of the box to
come up with
um the the thought process to have in
instead of our
um demise as a species uh be fungal
instead of bacterial
that's a a whole different concept that
a lot of uh scientists was probably
dismissing and the the game itself
showed how deadly it could be right so
again we are brought into this world by
the the genius mind of Neil
and taken down this path of a journey of
um Joel right and then he he finds Ellie
in they uh have this weird dynamic and a
lot of that stuff is embroached about in
the video game too much because excuse
me
the medium wants you to
um
explore
the movie or the show wants to tell
and there's a lot of extras being told
excuse me
that wasn't told to us in the video game
and I love it
because I'm talking with my wife walking
her through a lot of the process because
she's like oh my God this is crazy
um but the process of it is
certain things didn't happen in the
video game so I'm telling her this is
totally new for me and the backgrounds
of it is incredible
the scene setup
in the show
is probably like one to one with the
video game as far as uh the Aesthetics I
mean they really captured the whole vibe
of the game really down to I mean the
casting is spot on for every character
like so far that I've met
um in this first episode
um the background that you uh didn't
know about what a lot of pieces set
pieces from the video game uh is talked
about in the early stages of the the
show I thought that it was very
thoughtful in the approach and the
reverence that they had for the source
material The Source material is really
championed the source material is really
stuck to
in a manner that uh it gives it wiggle
room but it doesn't stifle it if if you
can get the understanding like a lot of
things that wasn't said is being said
now and a lot of things that wasn't
explained from the game is being
explained now and it's it's a real treat
for a fan of the series and it's a real
treat for somebody that has no idea what
it is because I went in as a fan of the
series and my wife went in as uh she has
no idea what's going on she's completely
oblivious to the world completely
oblivious to the characters uh I we just
saw um
Pedro Pascal in uh is just getting movie
called The Bubble that's on Netflix and
his range as uh
um as an actor
is very broad you know to play the
Mandalorian to play that character to
play this character and to give you a
sense I got a sense that he was Joe
I got a sense that he embraced the
character and I'm really looking forward
to it to see how far he takes the Joel
character and how deep he can go with
the emotions of the what's going to
happen because I know like stuff that is
going to happen and I just can't wait to
see it and unfold in front of me
yeah I have to actually agree I actually
you know originally
I was a little skeptical of Pedro being
cast as Joe right but you know after
seeing this because it's hard to like
visualize
Joel and nacho you know what I'm saying
yeah but there's this one scene where
he's speaking to like a guard
and it felt just like Joe was talking
like if like this mannerism how he
carries himself
I really like the casting now I feel
like you know people's like oh you know
he's not white though he's like dude
Pedro look like let's be real here he
looks close enough to Joel like his
actual appearance like yeah
and it's just like I think they did a
good job I think Pedro definitely stole
the show
uh the in that episode I felt like him
and Tess especially Tess Tess did a
really good job too yeah she was a
really good one to one it just that was
crazy right yeah
watching this made me even more upset
that we could have more stuff like this
but we don't get stuff like this do you
get what I'm saying like yeah it's like
okay Last of Us in terms of writing is
probably some of the best writing in
games right like the original Last of Us
but yeah the part that like irritates me
is
like my issues I have with something
like Halo you know I felt like the
original Halo and the Halo story is good
enough to be on TV told through live
action but I'm tired of these people
deciding they want to they they want to
put their own spin on it now go make
something else then like something fresh
because you see in the last of us they
kept it almost one for one on the game
so far right and it was really good
I'ma say this because I'm the only
person that's going to push back on that
um
the problem with it is
yes you want to cater to the core
audience yes you want to
um
bring across that story that they hold
so there but you want to do it with a
little twist
because
um see now
in this in this instance
you have the ability to add so many
different layers to it right
and it it still stays the same still
stays familiar you don't have the people
up in arms
but then there's the extra that we all
want to know okay so that works there
if a director goes into a space and they
see Halo as one thing
that's what they're going to bring
across to the screen they're going to
read The Source material and they're
going to say well you know I had an idea
what this idea could have been a little
bit better over here and I'm gonna do
this and I'm and that's how you get
master chief with his helmet off and his
cheeks out right and it doesn't fit well
with the core audience and the core
audience doesn't like certain things and
then you have people complaining about
them not sticking to the source material
so but then there's instances where the
source material is stuck to and it
becomes too predictive in nature I don't
want the predictability of it right I'm
sitting there watching this and then
when they went into scenes where it
wasn't in the game or this scene wasn't
there I'm like okay
this is more it felt like DLC for
something that's already written so
there's a fine line to walk I wanted to
know is Neil druckman
um really a part of the directing in
this so apparently he co-directed it but
that could meet anything like we don't
know if he was like he could have been a
consultant standing right there making
sure that Source material is being uh
followed you understand that they don't
go off script and and you know Joe was
doing a jig in the middle of the park
with uh with a fungus infected do I'm
just saying
I think it makes sense to have the
owners the writers the the creators
there to oversee such projects of this
magnitude because he understands what
the core fan base is about because he
cultivated and made the fan base so I I
think that's necessary to have when
you're writing or when you're directing
uh projects of this magnitude and it's a
very big project for me it is what what
you're saying is you feel like since
Neil was there and he was probably had a
lot of pull in the direction of the show
was going he was like the gamer voice
thing like look you got to keep it to
the core to some degree we can't deviate
too much it's okay to do some things but
it's like but as far as like the actual
story we can't deviate from that yeah
I'm pretty sure that he was standing
there saying yo joe will never do that
or Elliot never do that or or Sarah the
way that I crafted Sarah Sarah is this
type of person and
I think those voices is necessary
not the Twitter voices but the voices of
said creatives is necessary on set I
don't think they should do these
um
these movies or shows and avoid devoided
of the Creator's thoughts and and their
opinions I think it's necessary in order
to get a project just like this because
this feels like The Last of Us you can't
tell me you didn't walk away from this
episode saying that didn't feel like The
Last of Us
it it felt almost one-to-one to be
honest with you like and what I like
what they did is they put a couple like
wrenches in it to where you okay this is
what they did in the game but we're
gonna change it up slightly so it is
some kind of new in new knowledge coming
into you some kind of new information
but at the same time we're not going to
deviate from what actually happened like
what happened is set in stone but we're
gonna change some of the little things
in the middle to either hyphen what was
going on and make it make more sense or
to change it up so at least the gamers
have some form of oh that just happened
and let me tell you something I walked
away from the same Jim Ryan as genius
he sold a project he probably been
involved in the project he probably
watched the project
and
made sure that the Last of Us remake
remaster was done
because anybody with a PlayStation 5 uh
you know uh the new product for the new
people coming in
that has a yearning for more knowledge
or more control over the characters or
the environment or uh just uh Supreme
fans will get this product and it would
get it at a highest Fidelity that it has
been produced so far you know um I think
that's important because you have a
great project and then you have one of
the the best stories ever written for
video games in the in this pristine uh
condition that's that's something that
you want to present to the fan base so
whereas some people looked at it as a
money grab like myself who was initially
there from the the beginning ride
um I don't think so that much anymore
after watching this show and it was a
great judgment call on Jim's part to to
make sure that that it was told and
shown in that manner in my opinion
and to be honest with you
it looks good with the game too it's
just like you know when factions come
out not to mention part one just came
out part two's been it's been out like
people watch these couple episodes and
especially Gamers that maybe you know
you got a bunch of casual people that's
just gonna slip in and touch touch the
sand they're not gonna really jump in it
they don't really game like that they
play Madden they play uh FIFA they play
uh 2K Call of Duty and then they then
they leave you know what I'm saying yeah
now since they see something like this
well okay you know I got a PlayStation
maybe I should give this game a try they
might then stick around yeah and then if
they end up liking the other one you
know which is
um Last of Us they end up liking Last of
Us and Last of Us Part Two
now they're probably going to push more
cells on Last of Us Part three by just
making this TV show as good as it has
been already yep because I was
explaining to my wife
you know when I was playing the last of
us too
that was the first video game where I I
had a real sense of fear to move my
controller right um I told us I cried
like a a Oblivion idiot um
at a particular point in the game
because I became so attached to a
character that I couldn't
fathom something happening to the
character and and it was eminent that at
that point in time that something
traumatic was going to happen and it was
a choice that I didn't want to make and
I said that's the first time in video
games this is why I hold Neil in such
high regard that's the first time in
video games that I had that level of
trepidation with the controller in my
hand and it was a different emotion that
was uh brought across to the crowd I
don't care how anybody feels about the
last of us too
um my position on it is it's probably
the gold standard in storytelling in a
video game for me
so I have um
a side by side on the screen chat where
it shows Joel in the game and Pedro's
Joe and like look clearly there's
differences you know but no one cannot
look at these two individuals and tell
me that you couldn't confuse one for the
other you know what I'm saying like it
it's just I do feel like they they did
it man they did a good job with that I
felt like
there was multiple times or sure I know
that that's not Joel yeah but it was
like man he did a good job though like
he he did and what are you obviously
let's get into spoilers uh clearly but I
think we've done as much as I I guess
let's let's get into spoilers and then
we'll write it okay so so spoilers
spoilers spoilers right now guys and
if this if you didn't watch the show
leave
and come back in probably like 15
minutes
um in in and then you know you'll be
good because I'm not gonna go too heavy
I mean it was probably an hour long uh
show uh like that um yeah apparently
some of the run times is like
it's like movies like an hour and 45
minutes like an hour and 30 minutes for
a TV show is ridiculous that's for crazy
but you know what's crazy by the time I
finished that sure I knew that it was a
long episode but I wasn't disappointed I
didn't feel like I did like it was too
much I was like man first thing I
thought is I can't wait till next week
that's the first thing that came to my
mind that and you know the good thing
King is
at this point man we've gotten to the
point where
that doesn't happen a lot you know what
I'm saying like to get generally excited
over something like that I would
honestly say that that doesn't happen a
lot at all most the time we know what
most these games are going to come out
and do we know what most of these movies
and TVs are going to do uh but I will
say since it was a video game
it was it was a question mark we didn't
really truly know that they were able
going to be able to hit it out of the
park and the fact that I got it headed
off to Sony you know I have an issue of
how they handled Halo I know you liked
it more than I did but
I felt like Sony is handling the brand
outside of gaming way better than
Microsoft is currently clearly we got to
see what happens in the new season of
Halo I don't follow Microsoft for that
stuff
but I mean they at the end they they are
in charge of it man like
I'm sure they read scripts I'm sure they
have a lot of of saying what goes on
with their own IP in a movie in the TV
show
mismanagement bro
I mean because then you know because you
look at this and you say this is done in
in this manner it's a different story
that wanted to be told
and you have to ask yourself are you
going to follow the books are you going
to follow the the game are you going to
follow your own intuition what are you
going to do
this is why I feel that the creators are
supposed to be there to tell you what is
and what isn't you know what Master
Chief would do and what he won't do
um my master chief will not have his
butt cheeks out inside the the the the
in any part of the film that's just me
you know the helmet thing it was it was
some scenes in the game where he would
take his helmet off but you would never
see his face
so
that's permissible but
these actors also want to be seen well I
guess me and you went through that
already and we talked about that but we
have uh almost 90 people here and we
have 30 likes please hit that like
button guys um you know we're trying to
grow something and you guys are the keys
to help us grow
all right so into the spoilers the
initial spoiler that I can go with and I
don't really want to go too hard on the
spoilers to be honest with you because
this package is so dope but um Sarah his
uh
his kid
I have a deeper appreciation for his
sense of loss as a father
because of all he tried to do to keep
her you know safe
uh Joel is very deep in family he
believes in family above all you know he
loves the hell out of his brother blows
the hell out of his daughter
um and they had such a nice bond in in
the show early on in the film they were
able you know you saw them eating
breakfast and her making jokes with with
her dad
none of that we got none of that yeah
she was such a large part of um
his sense of home
you know everybody has a sense of home
if you go home you see a dog you have a
sense of home you go home seeing your
wife your kids
and you could kind of understand like I
will say in the original one I couldn't
really put myself in a mindset like that
because it was so fast yes you know what
I'm saying that and
to my knowledge I think they aged Sarah
didn't they Sarah was normally when she
was younger
or something they needed to do that in
order to show how she was able to go and
do uh what she had to do for Joe for his
birthday
because we come in on his birthday we
come in on his birthday scene and it's
just like the game
but a lot of things was missing from
that aspect of it and was told here this
is this is the great stuff about uh this
medium where they can just tell and you
don't have to control anything
and it was told great the whole opening
act where the pandemic
starts and how it starts from uh Sarah's
perspective and until we got to Joe
and how Joe had to be the family
protector even though he had to harm his
neighborhood you know he cared much for
his neighbors he he did because if
you're going to send your child over to
your neighbor's house without any
supervision you must have some level of
Love or yeah
when you get to the point where you're
joking about sending your kid to your
neighbors then you have a really good
relationship with them because it's a
joke at that point exactly
so you know um
that I love that aspect of it the little
something those little nuggets for us
fans that that they brought across
and how she died
how she died at that moment and how the
brothers are they will always have each
other you felt that like he cared for
his brother because he's like yo I'm
gonna get you safe and then I'm going
back to go get you know um Tommy
man in in those little instances you
know those are little tear jerker
moments because there are things that's
transpiring and happening my wife was
like oh my God no I knew Sarah wasn't
gonna be around you know for the second
act of this for opening bell it was just
like yeah absolutely it was
heartbreaking
heartbreaking
yeah and the actors handled it with such
class and then you have that 20-year
jump because remember he's 35 at this
point in time so now it's a 20-year jump
he's 55 now
where he gets the chance to meet Ellie
and
the encampment
the level of government
um
oversight
that breaks everything down into these
little dystopian uh environments
it was oh it was just so disgusting
because they build walls around and
that's when I thought about attack of
Titan I laughed so much because I'm like
we're always building walls around to
keep everything out and keep us in truly
are we really safe we're not really safe
if they really decide to attack and the
little jobs that Joel had to take but
Joel had to it's a one scene
that bothered me so much and I'm pretty
sure
it's going to bother a couple of people
but Joel had to take a kid and toss them
into fire a dead a dead kid he had to
toss him into the fire yeah that was uh
that was a crazy moment they they
because the kid clearly was affected and
they're like look we're gonna give you
this this medicine then we're gonna give
you food and let you play with your
favorite toy they're trying to sue them
because she knew they were about to kill
him because he was infected
and and
the girl the lady that he was working
with couldn't do it
she's like I can do that one
but Joel had the man up and
he picked up and he he he had to throw
on the fire and
you know coming from a man who lost his
kid
you know how hard your heart has to be
at that point
and I think the reason he got so
cold-hearted throughout those years is
because he lost Sarah and and he he
probably in a way blames himself for
Sarah's death so he's going throughout
this entire apocalypse like the reason
that I lost her
is because you know I I wasn't
cold-hearted enough I I I I may I could
have did something else you know maybe I
couldn't go look for my brother and that
that's resulted in in all that happening
and you know the chain reactions
throughout the years has made him that
cold you know what I like though
is how they built the relationship with
Joe and Tommy like yeah because in the
original one he didn't leave because
Tommy was missing people yeah and this
one they're like we're gonna give him a
reason to leave but Ellie just shows up
out of nowhere which is like an add-on
you know what I'm saying like Okay we're
going that way anyway so let's just drop
this chick off get this
yeah
this vehicle so we could go to him
quicker what I like is just how well it
was done so let's let's talk about it
though Ellie how did you feel like Ellie
did
I don't
you know okay so casting wise you got uh
Pedro who looks just like Joe
oh man
can you yo you couldn't miss that
casting with a baseball but you couldn't
miss it you couldn't miss it at all it
he was Joe he walked in there I'm pretty
sure that they was like got him sign him
up whatever he wants put him inside the
bag we got him
her on the other hand I really didn't
like her as an actress in um a Star Wars
thing that I seen
and
I I feel personally like I got some type
of ownership over Ellie
um like like
um
like I own the character I know the
character she doesn't look like the
character because we know who she's
supposed to look like uh that uh actress
that plays in
uh what's that um
Umbrella Academy the Umbrella Academy
yeah we we know that you know well
supposedly you know uh supposed to be
like her but
I had to take a picture
was I what didn't she take from the
court over Ellie look at it yeah yes she
did they did because they never asked
you yeah you know they did but that's
why she looks a little bit so different
when it comes to the last of us too uh
but she did she she was Ellie
her acting chops
um
brought it through
you said she was great in Game of
Thrones king okay
um if you say so I just couldn't stand
that it doesn't matter but she was great
hair
she was she was
um
I don't know man it's
you you become so entrenched in these
characters as video game players we like
we believe we know what Simon Belmont
would do or what Sonic would do in this
case or what Mario would do I want to
know the level of scrutiny that Mario
movie is gonna get which is going to be
nuts but um
I had to to let go and watch and put
aside whatever bias that I had uh
preemptively and just releasing just you
know watch the show and
she definitely came to play she she had
her bars risen to where Pascal was and I
was like okay this is gonna be really
good this is going to be really good
so
I still don't like the casting I don't
um as far as like a like a static look I
still don't think she looks much like
Ellie uh maybe she's around the same
height that Ellie is but as far as like
visually I don't I can't Joel and Pedro
it's kind of easy to see the two as one
but her I find it really hard and
but I can't I can't front
she plays Ellie good right but it's just
the the looks man and that's where I was
so hard to look past that like
but let me ask you a question did you
watch it with anybody that never played
the video game
no
my wife said she's fantastic
[Music]
and I'm sitting there with some
imaginary hate inside myself like no she
doesn't like and I guess we're just
gonna have to get over that clearly
because she's already been cast the show
has already been filmed so there's no
going back at this point and it's just
like
I guess
I'd rather her look not like Ellie and
play good a good Ellie then her look
like Ellie and play a bad alley so yeah
uh especially like she she has the the
mannerisms that Ellie has she always
dropping so some cuss words like she
remember when she got the knife oh my
God
she threw that bag at her and she went
straight for that knife hell yeah pokey
poke ain't no joke
yeah what I like is there at the end
when she stabbed the uh the guard yeah
because she knew that she was gonna she
was gonna test negative and she she
rather get the jump on him at that point
than give him the opportunity to jump on
them yeah it was good man uh did you see
the preview for the next episode no I
don't like doing previews well it showed
it at the end of the uh episode
apparently that's when the clickers are
supposed to show up the first clicker
and like it showed like a a scene of
them like against some kind of mirror
and you hear them in the background and
you hear Ellie's saying Ellie's like are
they hard to kill like no she says have
you killed one and he says yes and she
says are they hard to kill and then it
just goes off like
uh well I can't wait for the second
episode I'm gonna probably re-watch this
episode again because it was so good
um I tend to do that just much like
video games where you uh
play a level and the level is so good
you're like let me go back and play that
level again
so yeah I'll probably I'll probably do
that I do
have a yearning to go back and play the
game
and I know that sounds a little bit
weird but um I really do have a feeling
to go back in and you know play this
game again
because it's I mean I have it there I'm
I'm trying to debate do I do I get the
PlayStation 5 new version of the game
in its highest Fidelity and and to see
it through those eyes or do I wait for
the remake of this game for them for the
TV show I don't know I don't know I
don't know what I'll do but um I I'm
just I'm more on board I'm going bored
for this I thought it would be something
different I thought I'd have something
negative to say but I don't have a
negative word to say about nothing at
all and
I really thought I wasn't gonna like
this like I I and I can't
I can't imagine I didn't I just I
honestly didn't think they were gonna do
it because I've been burned so many
times what TV shows and you hear about
them not doing the spores and some of
the casting questioning and it's just
like
this is about to pull like but they they
they they surprised me that one scene
when they had the the you know how they
went down to the bottom when they saw
the decomposing guy against the wall you
know the fungus
and how like reacting area she was like
she they knew what that was like
he said as a the PlayStation version is
a mint diamond yeah send me the code
all right so I guess we'll we'll move on
to uh the next
topic uh you know did you see that the
next
trailer for the milando the the
Mandalorian the Mandalorian is about to
come out did you see that it's
apparently it'll probably be out by like
in an hour maybe it's out already
I was asking you why is the Mandalorian
there it's supposed to come out in a
in a football game or something Cog sent
it to me yes I watched the wire what are
you crazy did I watch The Wire are you
nuts I watched every season of The Wire
I know which string of bell came from
I'm an Omar dude come on stop it stop it
so when it comes to the Mandalorian you
know uh do we have a release date on the
next season look there's season three I
think they're on not that I know of I'm
watching the bad batch right now man
don't don't get me all hobbed up on on
baby groogle Who's down here in my
little cabinet
so what is your hopes for this for this
show more baby grogle more baby Yoda
people hate baby Yoda I love them why
why do people hate him well I got a lot
of dudes that uh that felt that the
Mandalorian became a a simp because he
was looking out for this little kid and
listen
Disney gonna sell whatever Disney gonna
sell he's a huge hit uh future Yoda is
gone right so of course well you know
grown Yoda is gone so now we got baby
Yoda we need uh that race to survive you
know uh yaddle is is no longer around
that was the female Yoda
um so we have grogle from that race so
hopefully they can explore more of where
they're at or
that's such a mysterious race and they
really need to find out more about it
um
I'm just on the ride for for whatever
the Mandalorian brings I thought it was
great storytelling you know Pedro Pascal
has linked itself to a lot of good uh
franchises and things that's going to
continue
yeah that's why that's the only reason
why I was like oh he put that there
because you know we just watched him I I
have no idea why you put them there yeah
they're a new episode uh I mean a new
trailer is launching today oh March 1st
for a mando
oh so that's that's that soon
yep that's too much he said there ain't
no baby that's a grown ass man yeah he's
50 years old
you you know what I really look forward
to this this the show was when every
topic is a new episode that week of
the week you know what I'm saying like
like we talk about the next episode of
Mandalorian the next episode of Last of
Us the next episode of this well you
know what I think is gonna happen I
think the same week we get a chance to
watch Ant-Man uh it'll be a new episode
of uh Last of Us
you know
so you know hopefully we have some more
stuff in there too uh listen guys we're
we're really uh pushing it you know
pushing the limits of um
of this movie going stuff uh
gathering information sitting down to
actually watch things and and review it
and watch it with a Discerning Eye that
we can come back and bring that
information so it's been such a fun ride
to to to try to explore this stuff and
attic is working very hard in the
background you know to to get the show
to where we both Envision it to being so
yeah man it's the Mandalorian March 1st
can't wait for that stuff some people
put in the chat they want to see more
armor more more stuff from it I want
them to explore uh what really uh
happened after all the 66 or or the Jedi
spread out Across the Universe does he
run into more Jedi
uh it's just you know stuff like that
because we got a chance to see Luke and
that was a great uh ending to that that
season so you know we don't think they
had a hard time fighting one of those
machines and Luke just shows up and
kills all star trees
what Luke's that guy he's the one
yeah so I mean that that's pretty much
all we got really talk on that you know
we will be covering that like in depth
when it actually does come out uh but we
got a little bit before that comes out
but we that we had some Ant-Man
information come out king oh oh so okay
anybody that saw the new Ant-Man trailer
who saw that uh
right
so you know Addie gets a chance to watch
it and I didn't get a chance to finally
see um who came to conquerors so addict
starts doing his homework man he's in
the background he's like I want to know
more about this King dude
because you got to know that you know
coming from a non-comic book lineage
most of this stuff on the fly right I
had no clue who he was you know what's
funny is like I'm sitting here like he's
fighting Ant-Man and I'm like but
in the trailers it looks like he's
losing you know what I'm saying like but
then when I actually like investigate
him like he's just a man with like
high-tech stuff and he's extremely
intelligent so like I'm thinking
everyone's super powers you know what
I'm saying he's got superhuman strength
like he's pretty much a Future Tony with
like stuff that times 10 of Tony right
and he can he knows the future too like
apparently to a certain degree
I like the the stuff that is um
the the tidbits that
Marvel tries to throw in there if people
ever remember y'all remember watching
The Avengers trailer I think that was
Infinity War and the Hulk was running
with the rest of the Avengers so we
assumed that it will be a Redemption
moment
for the Hulk versus Thanos
that was never there that was fake that
was put there in order to uh you know
banana in the tailpipe you know to to
distract you to throw you off to have
you writing different theories and and
it worked to Perfection so in this
trailer we see Modoc
yeah I did some research on him
apparently in this one he's supposed to
be the yellow jacket for the first one
that's who he's supposed to be and
apparently he's like some experimented
dude from the people who was in Iron Man
3. like that group yeah aim and they
yeah turned into a giant eye to a giant
head that has to be hot that has to have
hover technology to move around because
he's too hot top heavy now okay his
brain is his his head too big his arms
is the normal size his feet is the
normal size but he got this big ass face
and moduk is is a weird character to
bring across and the fact that they show
Moto
um
we want to use him but we don't want to
use him let's get him out of here
apparently they think he's not gonna die
in this in this movie like he's supposed
to eventually be like a middle person
yeah
doesn't die not like that
um he's he's very he's a very underrated
character right
and he saw he takes over aim at some
point in time
[Laughter]
he said King is gonna F blank up
yes he is
if if you know from The Avengers cartoon
show if you know from the comic books
you you pretty much know King is a very
very formidable foe
um so if you watch Loki's uh show uh you
know exactly who King is how they
introduced him there so just to clarify
because I have to catch up because I
didn't know who King was at that time
okay um I didn't even know that was Kane
I thought that was just some dude that
died in the Loki so apparently
he in his timeline won the war between
all of the Kings and that's right the
keys at the end yeah he was saying that
if you kill him you're gonna re-
instigate and start that war over again
so he was keeping them at Bay he was he
he won and he was keeping the peace so
whatever happened in that timeline it
was it was a peaceful timeline now he
said you don't know what king you're
going to get now
you don't know if you want to get a king
that just once complete war on chaos I I
looked apparently like there's good
Kings of bad kings and like apparently
the good Kings like started an
organization and then the bad kings came
in and killed them all
yeah so you got you got rheumatoid
that's a version of King
um who's one of the one of the you know
best comic book versions and apparently
the one that's in quantum
is one of the one of the strongest King
variables
is he like stuck there
we don't know
because I have absolutely no idea where
they're taking the story because okay
this is the thing Hasbro and Mattel had
an issue
huh whose eyes for old Mattel video uh
uh Toy manufacturers okay all right
Hasbro the the toy company and Mattel
the toy company one of the two has the
license for micronauts micronauts is the
where
the quantum verse is right they change
it to the the the quantum verse instead
of the microverse it's supposed to be
the microverse and there are the
micronauts in the the microverse the
micronauts is like The Avengers
we can't get those characters because
either it's Hasbro or Mattel owns them
and they don't want to give up those
rights they don't want to lend them out
they don't want to use them they don't
these things have been there for a while
I had those toys a long time ago ton of
comic books of the huge micronauts fan
now they had to find a way to tell this
story with using this world
that is exactly the same we have to call
it the quantum verse we can't call it
the microverse and we can't use
those wonderful characters like bug and
all the other characters that they did
have established so now they have to
establish new characters and and new
stuff there and what a way to bring them
there is to have one of the Kings there
maybe one of the Kings got locked there
by another king and he can only get out
of there if he can use Ant-Man in a
particular way to do so because
apparently he needs something and he
needs him for something but that only he
can unlock like it seemed like one of
those since if he has that yellow jacket
from the other one that there it doesn't
make any sense maybe because if you
remember at the end of Ant-Man that suit
was destroyed yeah it was pretty banged
up so I doubt it who knows he probably
got out of it at the last minute and it
just kept shrinking even shrinking past
that point so it because it to me if
Kane was able to re-establish him he
would have done it but
to me it seemed like he built that the
way it was for a reason yeah
and I think it was like a giant scar on
King's eye well yeah because he's a
different one he got his face split
so maybe that King in this King fought
and that can't sit this King here
that could be it
could have been one of the most
dangerous Kings and they protect him and
locked them away into the microverse
into the quantum verse
yeah and then I ironically Ant-Man shuts
up well what I hear is we're going to
get quasar
I hope so Quasar is a character
that is a very very strong character uh
in the Marvel Universe
um he uses uh Quantum he has these
things called the quantum bands
and those Quantum bands might be the
keys to releasing King and so we might
get a chance to see uh Quasar in this
universe I mean there's there's been
rumors and hopefully I I man I'm I'm a
comfortable junkie so I pray that we get
all these characters and all the you
know Glory but yeah that's what I'm
looking forward to I'm looking forward
to that to be honest with you
I think it's it's it's going to be a
good year
um I'm actually very I think
this Ant-Man is going to be one of the
key things to this whole phase five
because for some reason I feel like
Ant-Man gotta drop the ball and let this
dude out in some way shape or form but
to save his daughter
yeah that's probably what's gonna happen
yeah cause he told all I don't want you
to see this you might want to look away
so
I try not to watch cheerless but I have
to watch trailers now because of this
show
so you know I try not to I I'm still
that kid that likes the wonderment I'm
still a kid that that likes to be
surprised you know with so much stuff
that everybody likes to spoil on Twitter
and you know Facebook and internet and
stuff like that I I try to you know keep
that wonderment going still but I can't
do that too much now because we have to
do that but listen man we got 71 people
here we got 62 likes I do appreciate
that ratio but let's knock it up a
little bit I'm pretty sure a couple of
you guys came in here hit that like
button man please please it helps us
guys hit that like button we're gonna
bring you more stuff so do you think
ant-man's gonna die in this movie yes
you think he's gonna die though
there's always ways to bring him is he
going to get trapped in the in the
quantum no I think he's gonna die
that would be interesting that's what
February the 17th or something yep I
think he's gonna die so that's like two
weeks from now two or three weeks
there's there's other ways to to bring
her back because listen man remember
Scott Lang wasn't supposed to be he was
never Ant-Man for a long period of time
Scott Lang was a criminal who got who
stole the Ant-Man gear and he was
Ant-Man for a very short period of time
where
um
but this guy's really too old
uh to to play Ant-Man I think they're
going to pass the mantle onto his
daughter
Pyro
who isn't that someone that grows grows
and shrinks who because I remember pyro
used to be like p y
or o or something like yo pyro he plays
with fire he's uh
he's an evil mutant who has uh control
of fire Hold On free R Kelly with the
five dollar Super Attack Just as I
predicted The Last of Us show wasn't
anything special 6.5
out of ten Kelly
don't reverse roles
don't don't Kelly I'm supposed to be the
Sony hater you supposed to be against me
the show is fantastic Kelly please
please let's get right back to the
script you are the Sony lover I'm the
Sony hater it doesn't work good if we on
the same team for the crowd it doesn't
work good go back to being the hater of
King and I can go back to Hayden Kelly
because Kelly I'm opposed to you with
this don't do this Kelly come on Kelly
let's get back I don't know what they
putting your medication in jail but you
got to fix it up get right back to the
cows I love stop it
so I mean I think that's pretty much all
we could talk about today you know we're
gonna have to definitely keep track of
what happens with the last of a show
we actually have some stuff that we can
talk about in terms of
you know uh movies that's coming out we
got some movies coming out next month
it's gonna be interesting man uh you
know
weekly we are going to talk about Last
of Us uh until for the duration of that
show I think there's eight episodes in
all
so you're gonna have eight episodes of
breaking down that show uh so you know I
hope you guys enjoy yeah King you got
anything to tell the chat before we head
out I'm gonna tell you right now man
I'm upset but hopefully it all pays off
um keep watching uh the social media I
want to give a shout out to Brian who
came out and actually uh we made that
trade for that uh you know the
PlayStation you know for the the statue
so you know Wolverine is gone and um he
sent me pictures and it looks dope in
this collection right now and I'm so
happy for him uh listen listen guys we
got some stuff that we're cooking up and
tomorrow is a big day so you know check
out your social medias check out Cog
check out myself check out Sovereign uh
just follow and and see what we tweet
out or what we put up or check the
Instagrams uh check the tick tocks
because we'll send stuff over to the
attic but uh be on the lookout you know
uh very important stuff but uh that's it
you know r r is not tomorrow it was
today
yeah we'll see you guys next week when
we talk about The Last of Us episode
part two hold on Gabe AKA Kyle kiddo uh
kid six one nine with a great two dollar
Super Chat tank Davis is on his way to
being a boxing King
yeah if he can stop getting in trouble
you know you got to stay out of trouble
to get this fight because from uh what I
heard in the background I called a
friend of mine
the PVC is not sending a contract over
to Ryan Garcia while Tank's legal issues
is going up and and that hurts that
hurts a lot
you know because it hurts boxing it
hurts Ryan's uh prospects to show if
he's better than tank or if tank is
better than Ryan it hurts tanks
prospects in in having his name clear
you don't want to have you know charges
around your name so man I want to see a
great fight and you know we got to stop
getting in our way here's a legit
alleged stuff so
can't wait guys hey and we'll see you
next